[Music]
these two judgments give the thoughts of
good and bad a Content which is the
opposite of what they had for us but
self-consciousness was at first only
incompletely related to its objects that
is only according to the criterion of
being for self-consciousness has equally
however an intrinsic nature of its own
and must likewise make this aspect of
criterion and only when it is done this
is the spiritual judgment complete
according to this aspect the state power
expresses its essence this power is in
part the established law and in part
government and command which regulates
the particular activities within the
action of the whole the one is the
simple substance itself the other is its
action which animates and sustains
itself and everyone the individualist
finds therein his ground in essence
expressed organized manifested on the
other hand the individual through the
enjoyment of wealth gains no no
experience of his universal nature but
only gets a transitory consciousness and
enjoyment of himself
kua single and independent individual
and of the disparity between himself and
his essence the notions of good and bad
thus received here at content which is
the opposite of what they had before
Hegel begins paragraph 498 by noting
that in the previous paragraph 497 we
had an important reversal between good
and bad so that the objects that we
originally associated with them or
rather judged to do those things to
apply to state power and wealth
respectively the state power is good
wealth as bad suddenly reversed and and
wealth becomes good state power becomes
bad and you can find out you know why
just by going back to that but now we're
gonna have another reversal once again
in this paragraph so is it's these are
coming very fast on the heels of each
other
and what's going on for consciousness is
this sort of oscillation back and forth
that's going to lead us somewhere else
in just a few more paragraphs but first
let's talk about why there's yet another
reversal so Hegel here is going to make
the the fundamental contrast between one
way in which self-consciousness is is
understanding itself and the good and
the bad and wealth and state power in
relation to itself through making
judgments and another in some respects
fuller or more adequate way
interestingly generally in Hegel the
movement tends to be from the in itself
to the for itself but here we see that
what we've got is a movement from the
for itself to the in itself as being
more integrated as being further along
so he begins by telling us that
self-consciousness was only incompletely
related to its objects to what were its
objects both good and bad or more
concretely wealth and state power it was
only incompletely related to them
because it was relying upon as Cagle is
going to say the criterion of being for
itself the criterion being the mash
table you might say ruler or you know
measure is another way
thinking about at the wave of figuring
out how to apply these concepts of good
and bad what to bring under what heading
he was only doing so in an incomplete
way a way that made sense for it at the
time there's some things going for that
criterion but it's not as full it's not
as effective as it could or should be so
what do we have coming in its place
Hegel tells us that now consciousness
also has an intrinsic nature and on Zeke
write on Zeke sign of its own and it
must also make this aspect the in itself
into a criterion Amash table so it has
to measure things in two ways and Hegel
by the way here is not saying Oh get rid
of the first measure because the second
one is so much better and this makes
good sense if we think about things
dialectically what do we want to do we
want in order to understand something
adequately we don't want to just you
know get rid of one measure and and
throw it away forever and say we've
moved on to something better and you
know more complete no we keep both
measures and we use them to get
something almost like stereoscopic
vision of the objects that we're looking
at that's what makes things more
adequate that is our Haven or sublation
if you like an integrative transcendence
taking place now Hegel tells us that
when we do that what we're going to find
is going to put state power and wealth
into different lights notice that what's
going to happen here will go back to the
text in just a moment notice what's
going to happen here is an internal
development on the part of what's really
involved in state power it no longer
becomes this monolithic you know uniform
mass that we find oppressive that we
don't have any place in as a matter of
fact some of the things that we saw
in wealth our gonna turn out to be there
and state power so let's look at what
Hegel says he tells us that according to
this aspect state power expresses its
essence okay so that's nothing new right
that he's been saying since the very
beginning of introducing state power and
wealth state power expresses the essence
of the individual the question is
doesn't it express the individuality of
the individual at all or is this an
essence that in a certain way oppresses
it dominates that demands obedience from
it is that all there is so he tells us
this power is in part the established
law and in part government and command
which regulates the particular
activities within the action of the
whole so now he's thinking about state
power not just in terms of one single
thing but and this is something that we
saw playing out by the way in the
discussion of human law earlier on in
this spirit section alright in the
previous subsection of it we have the
the established laws and maybe customs
and then we have the government the
thing that actually executes those the
thing that has to respond on the spot
with perhaps some flexibility and
remaining true to those so now we have a
dialectic going on between them and this
is what allows there to be you might say
an adjustment to circumstances that
might be able to take into account
individuality previously it was wealth
that was seen as being so flexible that
could take everybody into account and
find a niche for each person and their
own activity and their own desires where
a state power was you know it's there
it's kind of clunky it's the essence and
you know it just puts everybody into
their place here there's at least the
prospect of something a bit more refined
so he says the one by that he means the
established law is the simple substance
itself the other is its action which
animates and sustains itself right so so
far so good for state power it sustains
itself and everyone and everyone else so
the government by being the government
is not just taking care of itself I mean
there are governments that do that right
thinking back to Aristotle and his
distinction between you know corrupt and
true forms of government what was the
fundamental difference
it wasn't who was in charge it was whose
benefit were they ruling for was it
primarily their own benefit of the
benefit of their class or the benefit of
those associated with them or did they
take other people and indeed perhaps
even the common good into account and
treat them as important as valued in in
the process well you know the answer if
you've read your Aristotle and Hegel is
is saying that this is possible for at
least some governments and the
orientation of the individual in
relation to the government so he says
the individual finds therein his ground
in essence the essence being state power
expressed organized and manifested
there's the possibility of finding
meaning a home community within state
power no longer just something that
oppresses one that tells you no you do
it our way
but perhaps something that says look
this is our way and we do it this way
because here's some reasons for it now
do you think you could possibly get on
board or maybe we'll try to convince you
a little bit more you know Hegel doesn't
go into any great details about this but
that's what we're talking about here now
this could be purely imaginary maybe the
individual is candy-coating as we say a
very you know oppressive and
exploitative regime but but Hegel
doesn't say that
there he was holding out the possibility
of something different what does this do
to wealth then wealth was being
construed as the good precisely because
it provided what now it looks like is
available on the side of the government
what is wealth provide us with well you
know we saw that the individual was not
an able to be recognized not even not
unable to find him or herself in state
power reflected right and they were in
terms of wealth but are they really
hegel hegel tells us here he says the
individual through the enjoyment of
wealth gains no experience of what his
own individual self no he does gain that
but he doesn't gain any experience of
his universal nature only a transitory
consciousness and enjoyment of himself
qua single and independent individual
and he notices the difference the
disparity the the disjunction between
his essential nature and as individual
nature this is why people can have that
that experience of you know surrounding
themselves with all sorts of stuff and
having tons of money in the bank and
waking up one day and saying wow this is
a lot of crap what what what am I
supposed to do with this how does this
actually give my life any significance
they may not actually turn to state
power to find that they may find it in
other places but that is an experience
that people sometimes do have with
wealth what Hegel here is calling the
distinction between their essential
nature and their individuality or if you
like it
between himself and his essence and so
then Hegel says look the the notions of
good and bad receive a content which is
the opposite of what they had before so
in the last paragraph we saw that wealth
became good state power became bad now
by the end of this paragraph state power
becomes good again and wealth becomes
bad again but they become good and bad
in different way
than they were before and this is a
point where we want to think about you
know the Hegelian dialectic you could
say well they're just changed polarity
change polarity again no there was an
advance that was made there's a fuller
understanding of what's going on and
we're using both of these criteria the
criteria that being for itself and the
criteria of the in itself
each of these two ways of judging finds
a lightness and a disparity in the first
case consciousness judges the state
power to be essentially different from
it and the enjoyment and wealth to
accord with its own nature well on the
second case it judges the state power to
accord with its nature and the enjoyment
of wealth to be essentially different
from it we have before us a two-fold
finding of likeness and a two-fold
finding of disparity an antithetical
relation between the two real
essentiality x' we must ourselves judge
these different judgments and apply to
them the criterion set up according to
this the conscious relation which finds
lightness is the good then which finds
disparity is the bad and these two forms
of the relation we are henceforth to
hold fast as diverse shapes of
consciousness by forming diverse
relationships consciousness itself comes
to be determined and diverse being as
good at this being good or bad not
because it had for its principle either
being for itself or pure being in itself
for both are equally essential moments
in the twofold judging considered above
the principles were thought of as
separate and therefore contained merely
abstract ways of judging actual
consciousness has within it both
principles and the distinction between
them falls solely within its own essence
that is in the relation of itself to the
actual
we reach a very important transition
point here in paragraph four hundred
ninety nine which Hegel is not going to
make completely evident for us in its
implications until the next paragraph
number five hundred in which he's going
to introduce these new terms the noble
and base consciousness now we don't want
to get distracted by that you know end
point you might say of at least that
part of the process but I do want to say
where we're going with this because it
might be rather confusing given the way
in which Hegel is is structuring things
orders if you look at what I've got here
on the chalkboard we're already doing
things here at a meta level and there's
all these different you know not not
quite antithesis but but certainly
opposition's that are taking place that
we're transforming into other ones but
that's what's going on here in this
paragraph that's part of why it is so
important so Hegel tells us that what
we've got on the table right now are two
distinct ways of judging of making
judgments
you know earth Thailand right of
deciding things bringing bringing
particular objects under concepts or if
you like applying predicates to them
this is all stuff that we can understand
in terms of you know a traditional logic
but one in which Hegel is unfolding into
a dialectical logic so we have made
judgments up until this point or rather
the consciousness that is trying to
figure out where exactly it fits in has
been making judgments about the good and
the bad and it's been making these in
terms of these two polarities of wealth
and state power and we saw there was an
important fluctuation that depending on
which criterion we were operating with
which mash table right which measure
whether it's that a being
in itself for being for itself we were
going to end up with different answers
about which of these is the good and
which of these is the bad and so we saw
them flip their positions around a bit
so Hagel is trying to put all this
together now at this point and he tells
us in the first case consciousness
judges the state power to be essentially
different from it right and what we've
got here is like and and different like
is also translating there's rendering
the same thing as what we've got here is
in accord with its nature Hegel is using
these two terms that he's been employing
for a while now like height org like
similar same in this case you know
accordant with right fitting in with and
unlike height or unlike not being that
and being being thereby different all
right so Hegel has said that at first
what we were finding is that state power
is different from us maybe where our
essence is but we experience it as
oppressive it's got no room for
individuality it's just something that
that we are going to label as bad
because it's it's essentially different
and and we saw that this is how he's
parsing these out and many people do in
fact think of you know bad is something
different good is something that's in
accordance with us this goes back a long
long ways it's not just you know sort of
ordinary persons conceptions that are
rude and and you know not very well
refined I mean you see this also being
appealed to necessarily in a lot of
substantive high-powered moral theories
you're going to see some discussions of
this and the Stoics you're gonna see
Thomas Aquinas talking in this way Plato
Aristotle can't avoid this even
Descartes you know is going to use some
of these things it's it's kind of a
common matter of recourse so it's not
actually a bad thing to do what is the
upshot here so we started out with
wealth as being something that is like
us or is he saying you know we we see
the enjoyment of wealth accords with our
own nature the nature of consciousness
then we change our ordering of judgment
here says in the second case it judges
the state power to accord with its
nature all right we found that the state
power does have some room in it for
individuality as a matter of fact it
might be the the locus in which we can
express individuality says it Accords of
this nature and the enjoyment of wealth
winds up being essentially different one
gleich from it right so in one way of
judging we have one thing being good and
the other being bad in another way of
judging we reverse those and the thing
that was good becomes bad and the thing
that was bad becomes good so what are we
supposed to do with this so as we just
throw our hands up in confusion oh you
know it just all depends on our
perspective you know crazy stuff we
don't know what to apply good and bad to
is that is that what Hegel says no we
and that's not what we do in practice
either I mean some people do there's a
little bit of a side note oftentimes
when people get all relativistic on you
there's a couple reasons for it it could
be because that's what they feel that
they ought to do right they're so afraid
of taking a stand making a judgment that
they they engage in this relativistic I
don't really know I can't who's to say
from this perspective from that
perspective right and those people are
essentially prisoners of relativism
they're not happy because of it most of
the time they'd love to actually be able
to say that something is right and
something is wrong but they've just been
so terrorized or you know shamed or
whatever conditioned into thinking that
that's the way you gotta talk if you're
going to fit into modern society that
that's what they do and they're not
happy doing it the other people who
often talk as relativist so the people
are trying to get over on you right you
know it's when somebody wants to swindle
you or get something over on you or tell
you
that there's an exception to be made
here that they start playing fast and
loose with good and bad and oh who knows
nobody really can be quite sure it's all
a gray area or any of that sort of
nonsense
there's really a wonderful scene as a
bit of a digression on a digression in a
movie the man who never was where you
see this character who is up for a
murder charge
his attorney comes in and you know does
that that's song and dance about well
can we really trust any perspectives
nobody really knows what good or bad is
you know just an unjust
innocent guilty who actually can say for
certain and he gets a mistrial and you
know he looks like he's gotten off but
of course they're gonna try him again
and this time he doesn't have any money
for the attorney through the
relativistic dance and he goes to prison
it's written I remember right goes and
gets executed as well because and the
reason is because it doesn't have
anybody to do that that sort of song and
dance as I said that stick anymore so
wiggle doesn't do that
Hegel's interested in figuring out what
the hell is good and bad right and so is
consciousness consciousness is trying to
figure out where should I be putting my
moral eggs this basket or this basket
where do I put them so how can it figure
that out
well Hegel says what we've got here is a
two-fold finding of likeness like finden
and a two-fold finding of disparity an
antithetical relation between the two
real essentiality x' we're in a pickle
to put it lightly right she says we
here's where we we make a a new step we
must ourselves judge these different
judgments and apply to them the
criterion set up we can realize that the
reason why we're in this this prediction
is because we have conflicting judgments
and we need to think our way through
them using the criteria that we in fact
developed this is where we assert the
power of consciousness not the paralysis
of relativism so what do we do we judge
the judgments Hegel says that we go on
and he says according to this the
conscious relation which finds likeness
is the good the conscious relation the
good is no longer now in the object
wealth or state power the good is in the
consciousness and the judgment that it's
making so this now becomes good and this
now becomes bad and if the consciousness
itself which is good or bad depending on
how it is judging things does the
consciousness find within itself in
relation to those things state power and
wealth likeness if if it does it is
thereby good does it find instead unlike
this does it emphasize the unlike Ness
that is a bad consciousness so he goes
on and he says the consciousness which
finds likeness is the good that which
finds disparity is the bad these two
forms of the relation we are henceforth
to hold fast as diverse forms of
consciousness the good and the bad no
longer lie in the objects but within
ourselves the observer the judger the
orienting ourselves in relation to these
things being the moral being
what does this imply this implies that
in the very act of making moral
judgments we ourselves become good or
bad by doing that
now isn't that fascinating maybe there's
a good way and a bad way of making moral
judgments this sounds as I said very
meta doesn't it
we're now doing things at a higher level
and that's exactly what the Hegelian
dialectic does it takes something from a
lower level and brings it up it
integrates it into a higher level that
is what's ablation or out hey bong is
that is how the dialectic advances this
is how moral consciousness develops in
time in history so he says by forming
diverse relationships consciousness
itself comes to be determined as diverse
as being itself good or bad not because
it had for its principle either being
for itself or pure being in itself
both of these are essential moments if
you remember a few paragraphs back again
in terms of sub-layer at what we wanted
to develop is a kind of stereoscopic
vision where we're able to see things
from multiple perspectives at the same
time so as better to understand the
objects in these this case the
essentiality of wealth and state power
that we were attempting to make sense of
but we're also doing that in relation to
our own being as moral agents as judgers
as evaluators so he goes on and he says
in the twofold judging considers about
considered above the principles were
thought of as separate and therefore
contain merely abstract ways of judging
but actual consciousness has within it
both principles this is what makes moral
judgment difficult to do but also makes
it real the fact that it's not merely
abstract Hegel is attuned to the fact
that genuine moral consciousness is
going to contain both sides within it so
he says the distinction between them
falls solely within its own essence
that is in the relation of itself to the
actual the consciousness to its objects
so where are we going to go from here
we're going to find the good and bad no
longer as I said in these objects which
we have all these relations of judgment
to those don't go away but precisely in
the consciousness itself aware of these
you know likenesses unlike this is aware
of the fact that it engages in judgment
and the fact that it can judge its own
judgments and thereby judge itself
you